all right let's start today i guess
we're calling this game do you buy it uh
we've talked before about the people who
have sort of softly come out against
donald trump who were previously
associated with them we've also talked
about the people who criticize him but
then when when it really comes down to
it they go i'd vote for him again
earlier this week william barr trump's
former attorney general said the 2020
election stuff trump was saying was bs
he was out of control and he brought out
a clown show of lawyers and then when
savannah guthrie said okay but if he's
the nominee are you voting for him and
he's like well i'm not going to vote for
a democrat
so that's horrifying and disgusting i
have a different example for you today
this is one of donald trump's former
white house press secretaries stephanie
grisham
my opinion
is that he uh she rather when it comes
to trump
has truly denounced him in a way where
she's saying she's out and here in this
particular clip on the view
uh or no not on the view on some other
show maybe this is the view um she says
he's a con man and i'm sorry and i don't
want people to vote for him what do you
guys think but my point is now i messed
up i am sorry i will say that till that
the end of time but i want to give
people an offering and i'm going to do
everything i can to educate people not
talk down to them educate people about
who he really is that he is a con man
that it is a cult-like thing and that
it's okay to just get off so you would
okay it is the view so um this listen
i'm not saying let's go out and elect
stephanie grisham to anything she's not
running for anything as far as i know
but if we're gonna kind of categorize
these things you know michael cohen who
we've had on the show
he
genuinely has denounced trump fully
and uh
is is cooperating to the extent that he
can
to hold trump accountable and i buy that
he he's off the train completely
william barr i mean i think he's trying
to sell books
i think he does recognize trump was nuts
but at the same time he even said i'd
vote for the guy grisham strikes me as
being closer to cohen
than to bill barr with the important
difference that michael cohen has said
i've always been a democrat and i'm back
to being a democrat stephanie grisham as
far as i know is still a republican and
the off-ramp she's talking about is an
off-ramp more than likely
to people like i don't know mitch
mcconnell mitt romney maybe or who knows
what so i'd put her closer to cohen i do
think she's sincere but at the end of
the day i still don't want her deciding
who the president is let me know your
thoughts what do you think about her
level of sincerity
let's follow up about school lunch this
story is just vile we've talked about
republicans and school lunch before
the news is that mitch mcconnell
is reportedly again opposing free school
lunch
the washington post reports that mitch
mcconnell is opposing an extension to
the free school lunch program this comes
as congress is deciding what to include
in the upcoming government funding
package you may recall
that again
we are in the situation where the free
school lunch the comprehensive free
school lunch program that was started
and expanded during the pandemic
has an expiration date on it
and now
there are
republican lawmakers including mitch
mcconnell who oppose including that
in a new government funding package
uh i have to tell you that this is one
of the most vile things like you really
have to
understand
the degree to which these people cannot
empathize with anybody else and we've
talked about opposition to free school
lunch from the right wing before
remember this clip from october where
fox news anchor martha mccallum is like
listen if kids think school lunch is
free then
i guess something very bad would happen
one of the things that kills me is that
now that you know there's a free lunch
program in new jersey and it's for
everyone even if you you don't need help
to send your child's lunch to school so
those kids are all going to grow up
thinking well school is lunch is free
right and then god help the person who
comes along and tries to take that away
these kids might grow up thinking school
lunch is free in
why shouldn't it be why shouldn't it be
in a literal sense
of course food's not free you understand
this i understand this it's a you know
people pay property taxes and it funds
schools
and you're paying for school lunch
sometimes property taxes include trash
pickup the trash pickup isn't literally
free
it's paid for through your property tax
okay
sometimes
it's good
when we pay for things with taxes and
sometimes it's not so good so for
example many of us would say i don't
love that my taxes without any option i
mean okay you know you we could replace
everybody to end the military industrial
complex and only elect people who won't
support it in any way it's not realistic
that that's going to happen overnight i
don't necessarily love tax money going
to some of the weapons that it goes
towards okay fine when we're talking
about school lunch first of all it's so
cheap
it's so cheap
secondly it's really stigmatizing a lot
of schools still have this colored lunch
ticket program at my elementary school
you know 90 years ago
um
if you paid full price for lunch you got
a green ticket
and if you got the discounted lunch you
got a yellow ticket and if you got
free lunch you had i think it was like a
red ticket or whatever it's
extraordinarily stigmatizing to do that
in elementary schools in a way that can
be really damaging to kids
and when they say it
we can't have kids growing up thinking
that it's free if property taxes cover
school lunch
what's the big devastating realization
that kids will come to it's just oh the
lunch is free we pay for it through
property taxes oh all right well i
understand it school is mandatory you
have to be there
but they don't have to give you food at
no additional cost at the point of
purchase you have to be there and your
property taxes pay for it there are kids
depending on the school lunch in order
to eat and republicans don't want to do
it
either because they say we can't afford
it because we obviously can or because
they think that children are going to be
taught some bad lesson
is it a good thing to be thinking
that
if you're a kid in school to be thinking
that whether i eat
depends on
anything other than just am i here can
my parents afford it or not did mitch
mcconnell extend the program or not oh
well you get lunch and you don't
it's absurd it's absurd and of course
it's not even really free it's just
prepaid that's really all that we're
talking about and when you step back
if you are a politician and you think
so-called free school lunch is a problem
then you're not even in the right
universe you're not even in the right
galaxy when thinking about the problems
that we have and mitch mcconnell now
joining the train and saying no no no no
we can't allow this to happen school
lunch should just be free period and by
free i mean prepaid
through property taxes as it already is
but for everybody rather than just some
people
news continues to be not so good
for donald trump's former
election fraud lawyer so-called sydney
powell listen to this texas state bar
tells court
sydney powell committed professional
misconduct
with post-election lawsuits
and could be disbarred
i'm taking pleasure i know that you know
one of my principles is i don't take p
pleasure
in the death of others i don't take pl
you know it's
when people have done really bad things
like the corrosive nature of sydney
powell's so-called election fraud
lawsuits she deserves to have
consequences and we are now learning
far-right attorney sydney powell may
soon face disciplinary action ranging
from a reprimand to disbarment for her
post-election lawsuits alleging
widespread election fraud as the
disciplinary committee at the state bar
of texas filed a petition in state court
alleging that she committed professional
misconduct through her efforts to
overturn the election
i i love it i there should be
consequences the only thing is the
consequences should go above powell
they should get to trump they should i
don't think they will but consequences
are in order here
key facts the commission for lawyer
discipline a committee of the texas bar
ask the district court in dallas county
to issue a judgment of professional
misconduct against powell and determine
and impose an appropriate sanction
can she even work as a lawyer at this
point in the sense of would anyone even
hire her like i guess there's probably
some trumpists or maybe people who have
absolutely no idea anything about her
who would still hire her but it seems
like her career is dead in the water
anyway from the
self-humiliation that she participated
in
the committee alleges powell violated
rules of professional conduct that
prohibit attorneys from making false
statements
using false evidence
bringing frivolous lawsuits taking a
position that causes unreasonable delays
or burdens and engaging in conduct
involving dishonesty fraud deceit or
misrepresentation
she kind of did all those things but
what the complaint points to are her
lawsuits in battleground states alleging
fraud
the argument being that she had no
reasonable basis to believe the lawsuits
were not frivolous
i tend to think that that's true now i
know that there are lots of people who
insist sidney powell is a true believer
she really believed all of the stuff the
election was stolen by joe biden and
affidavits and all this difference okay
there's a lot of people i think that she
plausibly believes there was some funny
business some funny business
but i don't think there's any way in
hell that she thought the specific
lawsuits she was filing were actually
valid i just don't i just don't think so
um let me know your thoughts
find me on twitter deepakman and also
tomorrow
is a trump rally in florence south
carolina
if you live in that area
and you'd like to be our correspondent
at the rally and you can get there and
you've got you know a phone and a
microphone so you can do some interviews
for us we'll pay you okay
info davidpakman.com
subject line florence trump rally
let me know if you'd like to go we're
going to hire someone to be there and i
would love to hear from you if you'd
like to be that person
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program the daily
podcast and the youtube clips and the
radio show and the tv show and the live
streams and the entire thing
is primarily funded by you
you can sign up at joinpacman.com
get access to the bonus show
get access to a commercial free audio
and video stream of the show
and get that six hours before everybody
else isn't that just the best
sign up at joinpakman.com
for instant access
let's hear from the most important
people involved with the show
obviously i mean the audience
we take calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to
vince from wisconsin vince you're on the
air what's on your mind
oh david um i'm just wondering what do
you think what punishment do you think
the ringleaders of the coup should
receive like trump ali cruz giuliani
these people depends what i mean listen
is that this is a question really for
prosecutors you have to figure out first
of all did they commit any crimes if
they committed crimes what can you prove
in court and so i i just don't know and
this is part of why i've said i don't
think that the general insiders are
going to suffer any consequences because
it's not clear to me what specific
crimes you you could actually
successfully charge them with uh we all
know that they
spent months
fomenting an environment where they had
ignorant rage-filled people weaponized
and ready to go completely crazy on
january 6th but i don't know that that
is a clear path towards any specific
charges which is why i don't think
they're going to be charged
do you think that maybe a part of a
reason why prosecutors won't charge is
that they might be afraid of of the
coming to essentially harm them in their
families no i don't think so i think
that i for me i've said before
i believe if one prosecutor charged
trump
there would be more prosecutors that
would be ready but it's i understand
that there are likely prosecutors who
don't want to be the first to charge a
former president because that is a
really really big deal in the context of
american democracy but no i don't think
the reason they aren't charging these
people is because they're worried about
their families i just think that it's
not completely clear they think any of
the charges will stick
yeah i just reading the other day that
uh uh the new york charges are sort of
fizzling out nothing's really going on
with that well but that that's a
different situation what appears to be
happening with the manhattan d.a is that
prosecutors quit because they became
aware that the d.a didn't really seem to
have any intention of charging trump and
they were like well what the hell are we
doing investigating that that's that's a
different situation i would say correct
what's the deal
it just seems like you know in this
country you only get consequence rich
rich and powerful people only receive
consequences if they screw over other
rich richer and more powerful people
there are definitely there's a two-tier
justice system in the united states
that's for sure
right and even even if i think they
should at least try even if it doesn't
succeed but
because then you set the president that
you can you can be charged you can
prosecute them that's that's up for
debate i mean if if you don't believe
the charges will stick and that they
will go anywhere
there's risk both personally to
prosecutors and and um systemically to
starting to charge former presidents
with stuff you don't really think you
can get them on so i don't know i think
some legal experts would disagree with
you on that
yeah if it's a low chance they maybe
they shouldn't but if it's a decent
chance then it you know it might make
future people future presidents uh you
know think twice about doing this stuff
i agree if you think you can demonstrate
it in court even if you're not going to
get a guilty verdict but if you think
you can seriously demonstrate in court
the wrongdoing
which often includes proving state of
mind which can be tough i completely
agree with you then charges should be
brought
yeah it's just it's just disheartening
to me but thanks for taking my call my
pleasure thank you very much that's
vince from wisconsin
let's go
uh next two where are we going next
let's go to peleg from israel peleg you
are on the air
hello david uh it's my second time
calling in i remember last year on the
october 17th jail talking to you it's
great to talk to you again likewise
um so my question is uh more general
about um
um
in developed countries or in developing
countries i should say
what do you think is the best way to
strengthen democracy there and build up
a system that is desirable
are you saying many developing countries
are democratic so can you clarify are
you saying in per in particular
developing countries that are not
democratic
yes also um
like um helping them economically to
build social democracy there um and
generally a desirable economic system
i mean the thing about the question is
it presumes that we need to be helping
every country i mean there there's lots
of countries that are developing but
we're you know we're doing business with
them we're
helping them in terms of industry by
buying things from them i don't know i
think it's a little presumptive to
assume we need to be doing more
necessarily i think that i would first
say prove to me we should be doing
anything
oh i i meant through trade and aid not
um anything uh interventionist oh okay
yeah yeah i mean listen then we we
continue trading i don't know i mean
listen it starts
what what ideas do you have
for how through trade you'd like to see
us
support democracy in another country
what's an example for example um if you
look at uh it's called the um commitment
to development index you could see that
it's very interesting the social
democracies and it's an index that
measures how much a country is committed
to
helping uh
develop developing countries uh and you
look and it has six metrics if i
remember correctly i don't remember all
of them but it's trade aid technology
health um
all of these factors i think are very
important and uh i i don't remember the
us being high up there in the least but
i remember denmark being
pretty high there so that that was
something i was interested in can i ask
you another question sure
um so do you have any book
recommendations
uh sure i mean what fiction non-fiction
what genre economics uh
or non-fiction economics that i'm sorry
i should specify non-fiction economics
let's see i uh what have i read recently
i read a book by
um esther duflo
and abajit banerjee
called
uh what was the name of the book
hold on a second this was a good
economics book
um it wasn't oh good economics for hard
times i would recommend that that's a
that's a sort of somewhat new
um economics book i've read that i
thought was quite good also angus deaton
recently wrote let me see if i can find
the name of the book
uh the great escape
um which is a really good book the great
escape by angus deaton it's actually
nine years old and then also deaths of
despair
by angus deaton i would recommend both
of those as well okay
oh yeah i'm familiar with angus detona
it's pretty interesting and i i've yet
to read these books better i'll show
i'll be sure to read them beautiful
thank you how's the weather in israel is
it nice
weather in israel uh is pretty bipolar i
mean
like uh we had
pretty huge rains which is pretty good
for israel because it's a pretty dry
country you know the kinet which is the
sea or
the lake i should say uh shrinking but
then we have rain so it's getting bigger
so that's a good thing but then we had
like a period of a month or so where it
was like relatively hotter and then the
rains came back yesterday i don't know
what's happening wow are you are you in
what part of the country are you in
so i am in ashkelon near ashgal i should
say but it's um sort of
in the
south center of the country but then um
i went to uni from the idf uh i went to
uni they subsidized it so that's in the
north like that's in the other half of
the of the country uh so and now i went
back for a month back to my home and i'm
gonna go back in the 20th of march um
back to the technion well a lot a lot
going on i think wolf blitzer's from
ashkelon i don't know why that's in my
mind i think uh but don't quote me on
that peleg okay i appreciate the call
okay have a good one all right there's
peleg from ashkelon
let's go next to daniel from taiwan
daniel welcome
hey david how are you i'm doing well
i was just um i mean
what would you tell somebody that's in
taiwan that's uh
increasingly maybe concerned about being
invaded by
an authoritarian regime that shall not
be named
yeah i would be um
i would be
very very much
uh sensitive to
what what may become a precarious
situation i mean listen i said weeks ago
i think china's paying attention to
what's happening in russia and ukraine
to see what is russia allowed to get
away with and as a result what might
china be allowed to get away with when
it comes to taiwan i am i don't want to
say i'm expecting
aggression
but i am
thinking it's quite plausible that there
will be aggression towards taiwan from
china so i don't know i mean i would i
would be paying attention to what local
government is saying
yeah i mean there's
i mean there's a couple things that i'd
like to say about this um i i did send
you an email about this um i don't know
if
i mean i'm sure you get a lot of emails
so it's probably just lost in the weeds
there but um
they i don't like the
i don't like the fact that
uh china gets to have their you know
state-run media and propaganda channels
on
western social media like facebook
twitter
instagram uh they have you know plenty
of youtube channels just spreading their
propaganda and yeah i just checked on
facebook only one of their
uh state-run media channel it's just one
they have many and just one has
over a million and a hundred million
followers on facebook
and i just and obviously
they're not allowed to have you know any
media channels that they don't approve
of over there so i just see that as like
this unfair balance where they get to
very successfully spread the propaganda
outside their borders but not the other
way or not receive the other way around
that's a fair criticism yeah and
it really it really affects the
conversation publicly and i just don't i
just don't like that um i i don't want
to take up too much time but i i also
just like to say that um
the people's republic of china which is
their official's name has never governed
taiwan in any century decade year month
week day hour minute second in history
it's never happened before um and i
would i send you an email suggesting an
expert on the topic um to maybe have on
the show um okay all right daniel from
taiwan thank you you've said it all
correction wolf blitzer reported
extensively from ashkelon but he was
actually born in germany so i want to
make sure that i clarify that just in
the interest of clarity this evening
um let's go next where are we going next
let's talk to oz from kentucky oz it's
been a while what's going
on hello david can you hear me yes i can
oh lot's been going on i'm so happy that
i was able to get through so
i decided to run for us house of
representatives here as an independent
okay in my
lucky four which i'll be running against
thomas massey that's who my
representative is
and um i've got the signatures required
to get on the ballot and i'll be going
to frankfurt to file this week and i
have a website
which is
oz2022.us which has my bio and platform
on it how many signatures do you need or
i mean what i mean is i know you got
them but how many signatures did you
need to collect
400 okay i have about 100 i was gonna
try to get a thousand just because the
more the better but i'm just uh running
out of time
because i have some other that i'm
working on that i haven't been able to
focus and because i've been trying to
get these and it's been really tough
because i've only been doing it like one
day a week when i'm off work right to go
signatures and it's not you know i do
that a similar you know i work for a
union and i do similar things for the
union and uh
and community organizing but uh
it is dangerous i was assault or had
people try to assault me two different
times while i was out canvassing why why
would just collecting signatures made
them want to assault you
well the first one happened actually on
christmas eve was when i started the
whole thing of getting signatures and um
the first one was just like a random
crazy like crackhead guy and he was
shirtless and it was probably like 40
degrees out on christmas eve and we were
in front of a church
and
he came up and he started harassing
these elderly people and was trying to
get into the church and then he started
yelling at me and then he ran up and i
happen to have bear spray like within
arm's reach and i blasted him in the
face with it and was
able to repel
yeah
um so
all right well it sounds like a lot is
happening what's i i don't want you to
give me your full platform but what's
your main issue going to be for your
campaign
um well the main issue is
taking control of kentucky's natural
resources and i want to see coal and
everything in water and other natural
resources
uh socialized or nationalized i i prefer
the term socialized because it's a
little different but
people here don't really that's a hot
word buzz i try to avoid buzz words like
that that trigger people and not wanting
to listen but sure and people like
oligarchs like mitch mcconnell have
controlled this the natural resources
here for 40 years and they've been
pillaging the state
and the these natural resources belong
to everyone and they should be used to
enrich the the lives of the citizens
not line the pockets of the oligarchs so
that's one thing and you know for
criminal justice reform is at the top of
my list
by myself being in recovery and being
through the system i know how corrupt it
is i want to see the change to the
systemic problems that we have
with our criminal justice system and um
well those are worthy causes oz those
are two i know we don't have time for
every campaign point are you uh are you
thinking of a slogan i think you could
play off of dr oz and kind of be like
i'm the oz that won't recommend drinking
silver or something like that that could
be cool
i'll say that twitter ain't big enough
for both of us when it comes to dr oz
i'll tell you that
let's logan's get smart kentucky because
kentucky needs to get smart
and stop electing these people that are
oppressing them right wow well oz we
wish you the absolute best of luck keep
us posted on the campaign okay
2022.us please check it out thank you
all right there it is
long time caller oz is running they said
to him sir will you run
and oz said yes i will so you guys can
check that out let's take a very quick
break we're gonna go right back to the
phones after this short break so don't
go anywhere if you're holding on to talk
to me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow let's
keep it going and speak to more people
we've spoken to a number of really
interesting folks already today
let's go to why don't we go to enrique
from los angeles california the city of
angels
hello david can you hear me i can hear
you fine
great cool
yeah i just wanted to say that um
what's going on in ukraine it's really
sad
uh it's horrible
and i really think that
um
i think that the world i think i just
don't see how putin's gonna stop what
he's doing
i think that he's crazy he's a lunatic
and that
he really yeah that i i don't see how
inevitably in the future like we don't
go to war with him i don't know it's
just pretty scary i think he's going to
hold
the country hostage with his nukes like
he's going to threaten to use them or he
might even use them i don't know i think
he's desperate
and it's yeah i mean i think you're
you're correctly identifying that
putin's personality does not make him
suited to just kind of say
okay you know what you guys are right
we're gonna back off it seems as though
he needs either some negotiated off-ramp
that allows him to save face and at
least come off like maybe he kind of won
or
he's gonna go down with the ship you
know and that would be
nuke usage escalation of some other kind
i basically agree with you about the
general concept here which is putin's
not suited to just say
let's quietly end this
yeah and then again like i've said
before like
how are the difference between
republicans and democrats
donald trump right got impeached over
that phone call with zelen with the
president of of ukraine right
he was toying with them he didn't want
to help them he wanted to get us out of
nato he wanted to weaken it
how are they not using this you know
what i mean
to why are they not putting it out there
trump literally was praising putin in
the beginning of his campaign hey russia
if you're listening the emails help me
blah blah blah
paul manafort working for him for free
all of these things regarding russia
it's like right there man listen we've
been trying i mean it's just if you know
fox isn't going to talk about that but
yeah of course it's like trump is now
taking credit for arming ukraine
when he delayed giving them those arms
because he wanted dirt on biden but
ultimately was sort of shamed into
releasing the a like we're trying to
talk about it but you're completely
right it's not becoming the predominant
story about what's happening there
yeah man it's just it's i am actually
i'm just really worried it's a really
nasty situation and um yeah it's hard to
imagine it ending in any way that we
would call
positive you know i think it's going to
end in
in a destructive way one way or the
other
yeah i mean and then just putin just
wants to rebuild the ussr i mean there's
no doubt about it yep you know he's just
like trump ego it's all about him he's
he's crazy i mean
the world doesn't want this anymore the
world is too civilized now i think and
you know i don't think even china wants
to you know reverse back to this type of
of conflicts in the war you know they
want progress they want to you know
they're i don't know this is just really
bad and i hope
i thank god biden is president i mean
can you imagine imagine if it was trump
i know i know i know it would be
and then fox would be defending
it would be crazy it would be crazy
my pleasure everything's good in la
uh well gas is uh horrible i have a
truck i have a i have box trucks so i
have a tiny little family business
and over the last you know we were
paying about four dollars for the diesel
like a year and a half ago yeah right
now my diesel is six something six yeah
i put gas yesterday it's just i don't
know
your fuel costs are essentially up fifty
percent
yeah it's it's it's i don't
it's insane like um we go to i go to
call i live near costco here
i love costco
and their gas is way cheaper right so
i've been putting gas there for a long
time and the lines are long yeah right
now even if you get there at 5 30 in the
morning when they open up the gas at
costco the line is around the corner of
the block of costco
wow it's just it's just so bad i mean
yeah it's really expensive here but
you know we got to do what we got to do
and
we got to support biden and hopeful
hopefully
this works out well now let me ask you
just one other question do you pass
along the increased cost i don't know
what you do with the trucks i don't know
if it's deliveries or whatever
to amazon's oh okay deliver for clients
yeah
so do you pass along the increased gas
price to your customers or do you just
have to eat it
uh
the trucking industry has become really
extremely lucrative uh when covet hit it
just blew up and you know the the people
at the ports like i know all about that
stuff the truckers the brokers they're
pretty much price gouging
clients um and it's this whole thing
since china is now able to
pretty much china can people in china
can sit in offices and act like they
have companies here in the u.s
right they are making a lot of money so
in other words like the client i have
now he start he's he's chinese born but
he was raised here in the us
he has an amazon business and he grew he
blew up he's the millionaire now so it
sounds like what you're saying if i read
between the lines is you're already
charging enough that the the gas cost is
annoying but it's not going to break you
no
i'm not because i'm a small company okay
the bigger companies since they have the
leverage and all the trucks and
everything with the ports they're price
gouging these guys and my i just did
raise my price 40 bucks per trip okay uh
but it's gonna have to go up more so
yeah it is it is but it's going to end
up in the with the consumer anyway so
we'll see what happens but all right my
friend well uh keep keep it up all right
thanks thanks man okay
you're the best thank you take care
there's enrique from los angeles
running a trucking business a trucking
business
let's go to eric from colorado eric
you're on there
hey david this is eric hey eric what's
going on
hey so i kind of had a question a little
bit of what the last caller said where
do you think that we would be if trump
was still elected and this war was still
going on
so i'm gonna be i'm not gonna i could
give you some totally cartoonish thing
where i could say like if trump was
president right now
he would be literally cheerleading
putin's invasion no no no i think here's
the way i think this would have gone
down if if trump were president when
putin invaded ukraine
first trump would have done exactly what
he did
in the first couple days he would have
said putin smart putin savvy putin's
genius imagine that what great land he's
taking he would have said that at the
beginning
then
the entire world including everybody
around trump would have started to say
hey you can't be praising putin putin's
choosing to do this war of aggression
like you got to back off of it and much
like trump did at cpac i think trump
would have turned around and he would
have started at least softly supporting
um ukraine's defense of its land
but but
i think that when it comes to
coordinating sanctions with our allies
the way that joe biden has been doing
trump would just completely fail and the
the discussions would be a disaster and
we would be humiliated and out of sync
with our allies rather than under biden
at least you could disagree with what's
being done but but at least it's sort of
like a coherent united plan i think
that's what would happen under trump
thank you and do you think that like
russia would have probably done more if
the united states would have been out of
nato
under trump so i i mean i don't know
those hypoth i don't i don't find tons
of value in those that type of
hypothetical necessarily that that
requires a lot more differences and
assumptions i'm just not sure
okay thank you so much for taking my
call david my pleasure there's eric from
colorado
with a very
specific question
let's go next to
so is it sir rob from austin i know
we've spoken before and i think i messed
up the name last time is it is it sarab
sarab from austin you're on the air
well
i guess we will never know we will never
know let's go to win from indiana win
go
hi all right can you hear me all right
yeah i can hear you fine
awesome so i have a question on
economics again
so i'm currently taking macroeconomics
and i've learned the effects of you know
spending and saving uh you mentioned a
lot about the marginal propensity to
consume yes and the multiplier effect
the idea that if you stimulate the poor
that leads to an increase in gdp and you
know economic growth and whatnot
but so so my question is
um
um so my question is
if you so the theory is that
if you stimulate the
or like demand right it it assumes that
prices are sticky right which is our
like prices don't change in the long
like in the short term i believe so do
you think in the real world prices are
really sticky
it depends uh on the industry and it
depends on the time horizon
so um i mean uh let i'll give you an
example so like
in the short term if you take something
like gas prices gas prices
respond to demand
and they also as we're seeing right now
gas prices respond to supply
but if you think about
for example the type of demand changes
that it takes to move gas prices we had
a pandemic where global air travel
reduced dramatically people driving
reduced dramatically and we saw gas
prices go down but for the most part if
we talk about
some stim some demand side stimulus for
the lower middle class in the united
states
the amount by which their demand for gas
will increase is not really going to
have an impact on gas prices it's it's
too modest so that's an example of where
the additional money
to be able to you know maybe take a road
trip or whatever
it will change the the sort of uh
life of the person getting the money and
now having more money for gas
without really changing the price of gas
in a significant way it's sort of like
asymmetrical if that makes sense so so i
think the question is always of what
good or service and over what time
period is what we have to ask
i see so
when we implement like specific policies
um
we have to look which industry right and
then
um because some some demand side
stimulus may
uh be a negative
uh be a disadvantage towards some
industry too right and with that
would that would you consider that like
good policy just the fact that it's
affecting
uh a different industry let's say the
service industry or like the industry
that is not really like a necessity so
well it's
we're it's getting a little bit muddled
what you're saying but i think what i
think the question you're sort of asking
is
if we think about demand side stimulus
as just being good because it gives
people more money to spend on stuff
don't we also need to consider
that increased demand as a result of
those people having more money can
increase prices and that might not be so
good
yeah yeah yeah that's it much phrase
it
you really have to look at it more
specifically and you also have to
remember that in traditional economic
thinking a little bit of inflation is
considered good you don't want too much
inflation and you don't want deflation
and i've talked through the the internal
logic of that so
just because some demand side stimulus
will cause a little bit of inflation
also doesn't mean it's bad i i apologize
because there's really not one answer to
this right right right i agree but it
sounds like you're generally
understanding the concept which is the
most important thing
yeah because i'm i'm in like this
i don't know like the middle phase kind
of like i don't know what to
unders like read or understand and just
wondering like i want to find like the
truth to this but then there's again
there's a lot of economic data backing
up the uh
the demand side uh stimulus i mean
demand side policy yeah i mean listen
you're asked you're you seem to be
bringing the right amount of uh
skepticism to the things that you're
learning which is fantastic
yeah yeah awesome
uh and one one really quick last
question um
uh do you so
what are your thoughts on saving an
economic growth because there's also
some data on that like countries that
save more leads to they tend to have a
higher economic growth what were your
thoughts on that well so there's a
difference between the micro and the
macro level i mean we've talked before
about how
given the option
of
giving a tax cut to a very rich person
or a poor person
the rich person is more likely to just
suck the money in a bank account because
they don't really need that money to
live whereas the poor person is more
likely to spend it and the spending has
a higher multiplier than the saving it
in a bank account so that's at that like
the individual level
at the same time
saving at the macro economic level
meaning how much is society saving in
total
is a sign of economic health because it
means you don't have a society with as
many people on the brink of not being
able to afford basic expenses so when we
think about who do we want to target for
tax refunds or tax credits we would have
one answer to that and we might say well
just putting the money in a bank
account's not so good as in terms of a
multiplier at the macro economic level a
higher savings rate within reason is a
sign of economic health so
the answer is different depending on
whether you're talking about macro or
micro
oh okay because but if we're targeting
if you want like for the benefit of
society
um you know obviously gdp is not
everything right no but like for the
benefit of society
then probably
tax cuts for the for the wealthy isn't
really the best option currently that's
what the data shows yeah
okay okay got it all right thank you so
much david all right thanks well when
with some of the meatiest economics
questions we've had in a while i
absolutely love it all right everybody
we're going to go to a break we will
take calls again soon
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
okay it's time for the mailbag we do
receive about uh i don't know a few
hundred emails a day but each week i
will highlight eight to ten of them and
go over them with you sometimes there's
interesting things sometimes there's
nice compliments sometimes there's toxic
attacks and pejoratives a little bit of
everything you can email info at
davidpakman.com but make sure you have
something really substantive to say um
one person who did not have something
substantive to say in any way
is this person who actually sent us a
message via facebook who said you sir at
least they're being polite you sir
are a vile and disgusting piece of s
your views and opinions are treasonous
and you should be locked in an effing
looney bin alongside biden and his [ __ ]
vice president
this i guess
is
well it's
this is a lot of different things um and
i guess it's also misogynistic among i
mean we can't say what other what else
it is um but it is very unhinged
we get hundreds of messages like this
every day
and one of the really
important things that we should remember
is you know when people email me and
they say politely
david don't you think you should do more
to bridge the gap
between left and right so that we can
kind of get people on our side and in
our way of thinking yeah i'm for that
when someone disagrees about the degree
to which business should be regulated
or what the tax rate should be or how
far we should go in mitigating climate
change
please those are you know perfectly
reasonable disagreements policy
disagreements where we can have a
conversation and each person explains
where they come from and we might be
able to
change people's minds or have productive
conversation at minimum the person who
sent this message
you can't have that conversation with
them there's nothing i can do to bridge
the gap with this person other than to
throw myself at their at their feet and
say
i'm so wrong about everything i believe
and you're so right and i'm such a as
this as this person says a vile and
disgusting piece of whatever
there's some of these people are so far
gone
there is no way to bridge the gap and so
we've got to go around them we they're
not going to be with us they're not you
no matter what tone i adopt on this
program
this person is not going to have a
productive conversation okay next email
from jane
about the outdoor ski resort mask policy
in canada jane said i don't think you
criticized the lack of masks at the
indoor state of the union address or the
fact that california lifted its indoor
mass mandate on february 16th but you
did complain about the maskless
snowboarder in ontario do you honestly
think there's a qualified non-political
scientist who thinks masks should be
mandatory outdoors at this stage for
vaccinated folks you claim to follow
scientific advice but you choose to
disregard it when it doesn't suit your
narrative
um listen
what on earth are you responding to
ma'am
i made clear when we looked at a video
of a dad throwing a tantrum and having
to be grabbed by five security people on
an outdoor ski lift i said in that
he went there knowing that was the
policy i have said almost since the
beginning of the pandemic it started
with
i don't know that we really need masks
outside and then we had data and then i
said
we definitely don't need masks outside
unless people are literally on top of
each other in you know insane situations
i've said it from the beginning
and indeed
the state of the union the rules were
you don't have to wear a mask so jane
this isn't about
my opinion about when masks are and
aren't necessary i've already said i
don't think the masks outdoors are
necessary because that's what the
science has shown
the dad humiliating himself and his
family throwing a temper tantrum because
he wouldn't wear a mask the problem is
he's acting like like a little kid
and he knew the rules
if i don't want to wear a mask somewhere
like let me give you an example
at gyms
for the entire pandemic you had to wear
a mask
regardless of whether i thought it was
necessary and i basically did for the
most part
um i don't want to wear a mask while
working out so you know what i did i
cancelled my gym membership i'm not
interested in working out and being on a
treadmill with a mask on but if i choose
to go to the gym and i know what the
rule is i'm going to abide by the rule
the guy on the ski lift knew what the
rule was and he ignored it that's the
problem it's not about my opinion about
masking
thorkl wrote in and said
jonestown was not a mass suicide
criticizing me i welcome it this is at
least the second time you talk about the
mass suicide at jonestown it was not a
mass suicide you could maybe call it a
mass murder suicide but many argue just
be a mass murder people were forced to
drink the drink and those who refused
were shot calling it mass suicide sounds
like everyone did it of their own free
will yeah this is fair i should call the
jonestown massacre
a murder-suicide there were a bunch of
people there who willingly took
the
flavor aid or kool-aid or whatever it
was
because they had been brainwashed they
did take it willingly some did not and
some were shot the children were
forcibly injected with it i will do i
will do better thorkl
and i will refer to what happened in
jonestown with jim jones in south
america as a mass
murder suicide i appreciate the
correction
walter rhoden said biden will pardon
trump
and nobody's talking about it
um
i don't know about that
uh i don't think trump's going to be
charged with anything so for that reason
i don't expect biden to pardon trump but
i know that at times past there has been
this
idea in the united states that
we don't go after former presidents
criminally and so we have seen pardons
but uh joe biden has given no indication
that that's what he would do now maybe
walter knows something i don't or maybe
walter's speculating or whatever the
case may be but i have no reason to
believe that joe biden
would would pardon donald trump if you
were charged i don't think trump's going
to be charged with anything as i've said
before
haley wrote in
could putin have dementia
she asks hey david long time fan of your
show in one of your latest videos you
talked about putin being possibly
terminally ill and that being a reason
that he's attacking ukraine do you think
it's possible putin has dementia he
seems to be overly suspicious of ukraine
and the west like he is paranoid of
everyone what are your thoughts on this
there's no way i mean listen
delusional paranoia is sometimes a
symptom of dementia
uh sometimes they really are out to get
you
uh sometimes some combination of both we
there's just no way to know and i
understand when you see these pictures
of putin
um at a 50-foot long table away from his
own advisors you think well either he's
really afraid of germs or he's sick and
whatever or he thinks one of them may
try to kill him and that's paranoia but
i have to tell you it doesn't seem
completely unwarranted i mean it's
conceivable maybe somebody would try to
kill him i don't know
so i think haley as much as i appreciate
the the hypothesis or the idea
i just don't think
i don't think there's any way for us to
know right now
and it may be the type of thing that we
could know in retrospect at some point
in the future
scott wrote in about the alt left
and says i'm really glad that you're
being authentic and speaking your mind
against all sides
that are counter to your ideas
ideals
keep up the great work and i look
forward to seeing your show continue to
grow yeah you know i've received a bunch
of emails recently from saying david i
really appreciate the courage to call
out other leftists that you have first
of all i don't really think that they're
leftists to be perfectly honest like
when i look at tulsi gabbard
what is there that's left i mean she
she's vaguely against wars but like so
was trump supposedly you know um i
this is not a program
where things are off limits or we have
sacred cows or whatever i just call
things what they are and it just so
happens that with the russia ukraine
situation
a lot of these so-called leftists are
saying very strange things and so i'll
tell you when i when i see that
andrew wrote in
about the word anomaly david i am a
geologist who works in an industry that
deals in
a lot in anomalies i am going to lay
down the law and proclaim your original
pronunciation is correct the correct
version begins sounding like the word
anonymous if anyone wishes to disagree
with me i challenge them to a game of
mario kart now listen i i have to tell
you i'm getting a little sick of the
anomaly anomaly thing go to the
merriam-webster dictionary
type in the word a-n-o
m-a-l-y
and you will see in the pronunciation
section both pronunciations are fine
anomaly like a garden gnome anomaly
anomaly both are fine and quite frankly
i'm getting a little sick of having to
defend that fred wrote in about russian
covid david i hear so much about the
russian invasion but one thing that's
not mentioned what's going on with covet
and russia and is it or could it be an
issue has russia solved the pandemic and
need something to fear or is the ukraine
invasion a distraction from covid no i
don't i mean listen
uh there's they're still coveted in
russia
there is
no reason to believe that we've gotten
accurate data from russia from the
beginning
and i don't think it's transparent what
is happening with kovid in russia but
russia has not solved kovid but it seems
completely reasonable that like most of
the world not all of the world but most
of the world
there has been a three-month two-month i
guess
a decline in covet cases and
hospitalizations and death i would
assume that's what's going on there but
i don't have any particular reason to
think that covet is quote over in russia
and i don't think the invasion of
ukraine has anything to do with kobit if
you have a different perspective
certainly let me know reminder we are
launching the david pakman show coaching
this is a little this is an interesting
new project we're doing
i am going to try to help others
grow their online platforms so
if you are already a content creator
okay if you're not this isn't for you
this isn't to teach people how to start
if you are already a content creator and
you have a youtube channel with an
audience or a podcast with an audience
and you're all good on the production
side and you want to participate in some
group coaching
i am
going to be coaching four
maybe five people in a group format
you can sign up at davidpakman.com
coaching you have to be willing to have
our coaching sessions filmed because
then we're going to publish them
to hopefully help even more people okay
that's the idea
if you're not interested just don't do
anything i got two emails from people
angry
and they don't want to do it but then
don't sign up
if you if you don't want to be coached
on growing an independent media platform
do nothing okay but if you want to be
you can go to davidpakman.com coaching
fill out that form we've got a great
bonus show for you today coming up right
after this short break sign up at
joinpackman.com
to get access to the bonus show
otherwise we'll see you on monday